Heather Tom's been doing soaps since she  was 15 and you gotta give her props for  stripping down to her undies my  must-haves is a spray tan because  everything looks better when it's tan  Don diamant is 53 years old but you  couldn't tell from his shirtless seen  wearing only a towel I've been doing  this about 30 years it's really no big  deal and as you saw we laugh a lot  while this married couples been getting  busy her sisters have been hiding under  the bed you've been in bed with somebody  for like two hours and you're like okay  it's time to go the finished scene airs  Thursday on CBS but we were lucky to  catch all the fun that doesn't make air  I'm starving